[Applause]
welcome to the second hour of the tony
michaels podcast
and bonehead of the week
what a what a great bone end of the week
this week right oh yeah we had some good
contenders we
did especially for the dishonorable
mentions it was like every day was
someone new right like we had to really
like up until what a couple hours ago we
were like and let's just do let's just
do this one yeah so we got the
dishonorable mention which i know
everyone will uh will uh feel us on the
dishonorable mention but here's our
candidates for for bonehead of the week
um we have uh senator kirsten cinema
which you know it's kind of a
kind of proxy there for her and mansion
like all at the same time i think we had
mansion on was it the week before is
that is that what it was um
no i don't remember the week before no
no we all listen all the weeks are
blending together man
like these boneheads these boneheads
just run together right yeah and we've
had so many on several times and then
this ethan schmidt i don't know if
people remember this [ __ ] idiot um
this is the guy that was out at the
trump rally but he's the he's the
anti-massacre that runs around and
across cancer patients right yep that
would be him yeah nice and what what uh
what a what a great character he is
right uh and then of course we have matt
gatz um you know
uh i don't i don't even know it that
there needs to be much explaining there
right
yeah i mean i had a feeling like uh
when the
news was released about his
ex-girlfriend uh right basically being
granted immunity
yeah you know it's like
many of us
was were like hoping that it was like
something was happening and it's just
confirmation that it's like you don't
just get immunity for nothing right you
gotta have leverage and information so
i'm surprised i didn't get more
attention this week but you know it is
what it is well i i mean again again
it's uh
i i think i think it got lost in the
news cycle but i think everyone knows
exactly what matt gatz did uh yeah and
and the fact the fact of the matter is
and uh i'd like to ask i'd like to ask
some some legal professionals on this
but the fact of the matter is to
the the reporting is is that this
ex-girlfriend that testified before the
grand jury
about matt gatz and his relationship
with joel greenberg
and the charges that joe greenberg has
already pled guilty to
is that she received some sort of
immunity right yeah yeah yeah in in a
federal in a federal uh jurisdiction in
a court and a criminal prosecution
it is almost like a unicorn for someone
to receive uh immunity from a charge
like especially a charge like
obstruction of justice that is my
understanding now
when you when you talk about
uh immunity because there's different
styles of immunity but
we all wonder why it took so long
because you remember last summer
everyone's like oh he's going to get
[ __ ] indicted like you know right
after yeah
it was because i
yeah yeah it was uh i because i remember
i made videos in
april i want to say like i made a video
where he went to hell and i made a video
where he like walked into a house and he
met chris hanson
um
which are not far off i mean those are
yeah pretty accurate yeah it's like
listen i i totally expect him to walk in
with the pizza
you know and
[Laughter]
yeah pizza gates right uh so
uh
yeah that was last like march or april
and i feel like oh yeah we're going to
get him right like right well i mean
everyone was saying june or july right
they were right
but see here's the thing and i always i
always thought that there was something
going on why they weren't indicting him
i and i actually at some point i i you
know surmised that matt gatz might be
flipping himself on other people because
that would cause an indictment not to be
unsealed if there was a sealed
indictment or to to put an indictment on
hold to see where that process would go
but now we find out that
an ex-girlfriend who is basically uh
committing obstruction of justice and i
believe it was in her role of trying to
cover up uh some of matt gatt's bad
deeds with joel greenberg
is that
when when um that obstruction of justice
um
criminal liability for her came about
she probably went in and i don't know
how many dozen proffers she probably did
but here's the thing
uh one thing i do know is that the
federal government and federal
prosecutors are not going to grant you
immunity from a charge like obstruction
of justice if you do not have receipts
yeah yeah it's yeah and they're going to
want to see those receipts and then
they're going to want to test have you
testify about those receipts in front of
a grand jury which we now know that she
has done that so yeah and i think that
you know there are a couple people that
i chatted with this week and they were
like hey so
you know like
how does this work and i was like listen
i am no
legal expert and i've only watched so
much law and order but what i can tell
you i've done your own research yeah
what i can tell you is that these offers
or like getting immunity isn't like a a
whatever kind of thing like like i said
before you you have to have leverage you
have to have something
that proves
that the information you have
is strong enough to
say you know like i can show my cards
now give me what i asked for right one
and i mean that's that's the word slam
dunk right i mean i think i think a lot
of people were kind of using that word
um but that's the indication here is
because if she is granted immunity for
those obstruction of justice charges
she is providing receipts and right not
only
what i was going to say the reason being
is like you know she either
had
information that she was privy to that
she never reported on she was in somehow
you know she was involved in some way
like there has to be something that
would put her own innocence at risk
for her to say you know what i i need
like whatever happens
i need to have just completely hands off
free of any of this show that's about to
happen and that's a good point because
when you when when you have a federal
proffer and i think it was a couple of
weeks ago popock um when he came on and
i was trying to get him in today but
he's he's busy today because i wanted
him to ask him some questions about uh
the rudy giuliani and the fake electors
and what jurisdiction that's under
whether that's going to be a federal
jurisdiction or a state jurisdiction but
back to this matt gets immunity thing
um
when when you go do a federal proper
if if you're
like um popock said you can you know say
it's a murder to make it easy right and
you go tell them where the body is
because you know where the body is now
you're you're not they can't use the
information that you're giving in court
but that doesn't mean if they dig up
information beyond that federal profit
that you committed crimes yeah that you
can be held
liable for those criminal
charges so in this case with the
ex-girlfriend she could go in and
proffer right she could go in and tell
the federal prosecutors this this this
and this and protect herself from that
evidence ending up in court but if the
federal prosecutors find find evidence
of that of obstruction of justice which
they would have i mean it's going to be
probably pretty obvious where this
obstruction charges came on her that's
why her attorneys would have negotiated
very hard for many proffers to walk all
the way to the immunity
and again they just it's a [ __ ]
unicorn in federal court federal
prosecutors got all the time all the
money in the world they don't give a
[ __ ] and they're not going to just grant
anyone immunity so i think the most
significant thing out of this matt
gatt's case uh why he's so [ __ ] here
is because not just because she
testified before the grand jury but
because she she has [ __ ] real
receipts and they are
quote unquote a slam dunk and the
prosecutors view it that way because
they were because they were willing to
make sure that she got immunity from her
obstruction of justice charges yeah
so i think that's significant so um you
know
obviously [ __ ] matt gets yeah [ __ ] him
yeah all the way right oh yeah right all
the way off
[ __ ] bonehead um and i i know he'll
make us i mean he'll make back on the
list uh before oh yeah yeah
you know and the last thing i'll say on
him is i was talking with a buddy the
other day and we were talking about like
exactly what the expectation would be in
terms of
does he like at what point does he
jump out because he's up for re-election
right his term ends in 2023 so
uh january 3rd 2023 so it means like
he's going to be going through an
election cycle this year for midterms so
he's up which means that he either
like icarus flies too close to the sun
and his ego and you know hubris gets too
large and he doesn't want to back away
or
he uh
he sends in his letter
resignation
right as the fbi are [ __ ] storming
his door to arrest him you know i don't
know i think it's going to be one or the
other well i mean i i would hope that he
actually becomes the candidate and he's
on the ballot oh i hope so oh yeah you
know i mean politically i mean this is
the risk that the republican party is
taking with these [ __ ] seditionists
and and these [ __ ] these [ __ ]
sexual predators these goddamn chomos
like matt yeah and these others
this is the risk that you take when you
put these people on the ballot i mean
you gotta love the projecting too so
right right of course
you see our results here from from um
everyone who voted we've got we've got
eighty percent per cinema um four point
three and i actually voted for ethan
schmidt here to give him a head start
and it didn't work at all
it didn't work at all that guy i i feel
like that that guy has been given a head
start so many times in his life right
and he has never been able to whether
it's hey oh my god i mean like from the
videos i saw a video the other day that
he was re-watching
himself get owned by that kid wait wait
so he's watching a video of himself
getting owned
yeah there's a video so there's a video
that came out a few months ago where he
there's a kid with a dare shirt on and i
forgot if he was like selling or he was
like getting a donation for something
but this this uh
ethan schmidt came up and gave him a big
heart like let me see if i can find it
and then uh okay yeah yeah you can you
can send the link here but but you know
the one thing that he got a head start
on and he still can't figure out is
growing a beard did you notice that that
guy yeah like dude just give it up just
shave that [ __ ] trim it or
something
you can't it's not working it looks like
[ __ ]
it looks like [ __ ] [ __ ] you look like
a cuck um so
ethan ethan schmidt was uh was of course
the uh the biggest loser this week on um
bonehead of the week but matt gatz came
in second chris kirsten sent him in
first with almost 80 percent
but i do want to to uh give a shout out
to her
dishonorable mention because i know we
can talk about this for a while i'm sure
if he was in if that if this
dishonorable mention was in the running
earlier in the week or we had put the
poll later i feel like he might have had
it which is like oh
for the reason for the reason that he's
the dishonorable mention this week um i
i believe that he would have gained like
rand paul did the week that he got owned
by dr fauci that was last week wasn't i
can't remember they all [ __ ] run
together here like you said but um
uh mitch mcconnell would have had like
98 of the vote with what he said
yesterday i love this uh mitch please
hashtag by the way oh yeah oh [ __ ] yeah
i think you need to keep this going
because this isn't just mitch
mcconnell's um feeling about this right
yeah i mean it's not just he just
happened to he just happened to say the
quiet part aloud you know right whether
it whether it's his old age or he was
tired or whatever he just let that [ __ ]
just slip right out
and uh
and yeah i mean well some people were
like oh well well he he he meant to say
this no he did not get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ] he did not he said
what he meant that's right what he said
that's right they and and honestly i
would not put it past mitch mcconnell to
to intentionally say that [ __ ] the way
he said it is to project that
black voters are not americans they're
different they're the other you know
i've talked about this several times and
we've talked about it several times that
they're predisposed or pre-programmed of
this us and others right right it's not
us versus them it's us and others that's
the fascist thing that they do right and
that's what he's projecting here when he
says this thing
oh totally and i mean like it's not just
you know it's not just african-americans
that he's like separating to be like
he's just saying whites versus anyone
else exactly what and that's what the
statement is really saying is that only
white republicans are americans is
basically exactly is basically what he's
saying yeah because when he says
americans that's what he means because
they don't they don't think they don't
think people of other ideology are are
americans or whatever
people of color
um and really you know we see it as
their freak out begins
on new york city trying to allow uh
citizens of the city vote in municipal
elections
um and they're freaking the [ __ ] out
because they're like oh my god this is a
slippery slope to people who live and
participate and work and pay taxes to
vote yes yeah it is gonna be a slippery
slope for you dumb [ __ ] like
why in the [ __ ] should someone who
spends their entire their entire life in
this country who who who not only gives
their entire production to the country
who lives works breathes sleeps goes to
church participates gets educated in our
communities shouldn't have a say in them
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
like i understand the citizenship
question and you know it it's a long
road for
non-citizens who live here permanently
yeah and i wonder i wonder who made it
that way too you know why
i wonder hmm
i wonder i wonder what white dudes you
know white white sweaty ball sacks made
that a possibility um i got this video
up of you um uh that you sent me here
so this is ethan schmidt who is uh
basically he's harassing this dare kid
okay about wearing a mask the kid owns
them and then there's another there's
another video
that i found on reddit later uh where
he's watching the video of this kid own
him and he still doesn't get it like he
runs head first into it and then yeah
like he watches himself but run in first
into it
yeah yeah well let's this has got 1.9
million views yeah yeah holy [ __ ] um um
there's another one out there of this
guy where he goes into that i saw him
first and he almost gets his ass knocked
out because he goes into like this
it's like a walgreens or something where
someone's trying to get vaccinated and
the guy's wearing a mask trying to get
accident and he's like up in the grill
while the guy is trying to give action
he's like get the [ __ ] away from me like
i'm gonna beat the sh living [ __ ] out of
you if you don't leave me the [ __ ] alone
i'm here to get vaccinated and that's
the craziest part about this idiot that
we're probably going to see in this clip
because i don't know that i've seen this
one is that they say my body my choice
my body my choice and what they mean is
my choice your body
my choice your body because that
they they want to make sure that other
people can't wear masks and can't get
vaccinated right that's what they want
but also it's just again like you know
we talked about earlier this week and we
you know we talked about with jeremy as
well uh during the interview it's like
they
actively
willingly actively choose to go out of
their way they will travel across the
[ __ ] country to another
to another country
and harass someone for
they arrest someone that they don't know
about something that does not involve
them that in an area in which they do
not live they never go to like they are
willing to travel to the ends of the
earth to harass someone over wearing a
mask on someone else's body right well
and you know they're doing it they're
doing it inside school boards and city
councils right you see so many of these
meetings videos from these meetings
where they're losing their [ __ ] minds
oh yeah i mean just just i mean even
people
uh you know even for people like matt
walsh who homeschools as kids he still
shows up to to school board meetings and
harasses them and talks about [ __ ] when
it doesn't even make sense he
homeschools his kids and you know puts
them through his own indoctrination
right your body your choice right right
so don't show up and start putting in
your own politics about kids
in a school that doesn't even involve
you well and that and you know that's
what they're doing because i've been in
these twitter spaces i don't know if
anyone out there gets in these twitter
spaces some of these pro-democracy
twitter spaces but i've been uh speaking
in some of those and i'll tell you that
there's a few people in there that go
talk about they'll talk about um
going to local school board meetings and
when these people show up and they're
they're saying crazy ass [ __ ] into the
microphone number one i don't know why
they're letting say this crazy ass [ __ ]
into a microphone it's not their freedom
of speech to to say crazy [ __ ] in an
official proceeding i mean they get to
speak and give their opinion but to say
crazy misinformation and official
proceeding is not your freedom of speech
but anyways that's beside the point
um when they approach these people ask
them who they are where they're from
these people like run away they won't
say anything because these people aren't
from those school districts they're
[ __ ] they're going there
outside of their school district just to
say crazy [ __ ] into a microphone to get
people inside the district to believe
that there's parents that believe that
garbage right you know oh well someone
else it's that it's the social it's the
social um what do you call it uh you
know acceptance and that's not the word
but you know they they get this they get
this oh someone else believes that and
that's what facebook is you're talking
about like social proof yeah social
proof yeah
right yeah social proof and validation
and that's what facebook has done a lot
with like this ivermectin and the
anti-backs and the anti-mass
you know they have these feelings which
i mean everyone doubts
doubt certain things humans have doubt
that's just and actually you should have
a little bit of doubt like you should
question things right it's not a bad
thing scientific method right you should
question things but when you when you
get this social proof uh on like
facebook or any other kind of social
media platform or inside of a a school
board meeting that you attend and you
see oh my god there's parents that are
schools that believe these these things
maybe they're true you know that's where
it perpetuates this [ __ ] let's let's
watch this video this bonehead oh you
triggered you triggered i'm not
triggered you're just an [ __ ]
[Laughter]
anybody that wears a mask is a traitor
to the united states what the [ __ ] are
you talking about you're traded to
freedom across people are not
comfortable talking to you if you don't
have a mask on it's my job look kids get
expelled from school if they don't wear
masks i don't give a [ __ ] i'm not in
school that's tyranny dude they're
abusing little kids so you're enabling
that bro
whatever bro all right how does it feel
how does it feel to be a tyranny bro
don't walk away i need your name you can
either delete that video or you can
donate this guy's triggered because
this guy's triggered because because
shut the [ __ ] up you little [ __ ]
nothing i'm not about to saw you and go
to jail i got [ __ ] to lose unlike you
you're out here with no job just walking
around recording people [ __ ] ass
yeah oh
[ __ ] you all right
so are you going to donate or are you
going to sign a rule we're in a mess do
you a beta wearing a man
bro then why don't you put me in my
place i'm talking to you like an
alcoholic
200 years ago i would love to bro but
that was crazy because it's 20 21 and
you totally could but you're not just
fight people like honestly
i wish we could dance
i really wish
he will he will keep wearing that mask
because he's a lot stronger than let's
start when you know i just wanna i just
want to point out for all the alpha
[ __ ] cucks out there
yeah go ahead the
concept of being an alpha means that
there can only be one there is only one
which means the rest are [ __ ] betas
right so you figure out which wait wait
you mean there's you mean there's
definitions to words
god man you know i guess so but what i'm
gonna say is that
all of these
alpha wannabe but really betas they
better figure out who the one true alpha
is because
the rest of you are a beta you are tier
two and lower you are not
listen there's some dude who
is is stronger better smarter whatever
the classification he's the alpha right
or she's the alpha or they're the alpha
i don't [ __ ] care someone is the
alpha and you saying that you're the
alpha and someone else of the beta just
means that you're really the [ __ ]
beta
right well
and half having to go around and
pointing out like he thought he thought
oh i'll go pick on this skinny kid right
right i'll go pick i'll go pick on this
skinny kid and he'll back down and he'll
be a little [ __ ] and you know he won't
he won't get my face and all this [ __ ]
nope nope this kid's like [ __ ] you you
want to go let's go yeah and mike my
guess is the way that the way that
easton schmidt you know wears his beard
you know his cuck beard that he's got
no one wears a beard like that and he's
not a cuck um
look this kid this kid with the mask
because he he knows his [ __ ] obviously
he's doing something that he wants to do
right he's confident he's confident
enough to be out talking to people get
getting donations getting a mask yeah
he would beat the ever living [ __ ] oh
yeah he's never living [ __ ] out of i
just love how ethan schmidt goes oh man
like 200 years like i could totally just
like but yeah it's like what does that
mean 200 years ago and now i don't
i have no idea like what 200 years ago
would would put us right
i don't even know what was happening
like specifically like
law or or just the you know crime or
violence i'm not sure exactly what he's
referencing probably something i'm
scared that has been misquoted found on
some ivermectin facebook groups
somewhere
some some cuck thread on reddit right
exactly you know alphacuts.com i'm gonna
i'm not gonna make it i'm
gabe's looking on this phone right now
oh [ __ ] i gotta buy the i gotta buy the
[ __ ] yeah i gotta buy the [ __ ] i
might
i might not do that this is live no one
do it yeah go go go hurry up go go
secure it all right it's available i'm
gonna do it i'm just gonna make a
[ __ ] yeah i'm gonna okay so so we're
gonna buy we're gonna here we are live
on on should we do should i do alpha
alpha cucks alpha cucks right like c c
yeah right because yeah yeah what what
because again again if you are saying
that you're the alpha and you're not you
are you are a cuck meaning you there are
cucks because they're they're cocking it
right exactly
you know and and
it's it's it's funny because um a real
true person who's an alpha like of a
group or something like that doesn't
have to say
like doesn't have to announce like the
alphabet right exactly like that's the
whole point of being the alphas you
don't have to announce yeah it's like
the person that when you're in a anyway
boom alphacuts.com iowa got it okay well
well uh jalen said toby morton will oh
toby yeah i love talking to you great no
yeah but [ __ ] toby we got it now
we got it it's just gonna be like i
think the idea here being it's gonna be
just like fbi is most wanted except it's
just gonna be a bunch of photos of cucks
just a bunch of [ __ ] apple ones right
wing manga
uh charlie kirk and shapiro ben shapiro
and [ __ ] schmidt joe rogan all those
[ __ ] matt matt walsh yeah well you do
you see the matt walsh thing uh he trend
he was trying dr
this is the thing and and speaking of
alpha cucks
there's no bigger alpha cuck than this
matt walsh guy and i said this yesterday
listen if you're a dude
and you're s and you're talking about
how how you're afraid that that uh a
trans woman is tricking other men you're
scared you're [ __ ] gay
you're scared you're terrified what are
you so scared for like literally their
entire fear is based on that they go to
a bar they see a beautiful woman the
beautiful woman
sees them as some alpha not an alpha
cuck but sees them as an alpha
presents themselves in a situation where
they would have sex with them and they
go back to the room and find out either
they are a man or were a man or whatever
right right this is their entire [ __ ]
fear that is based on this logic but i
also want to preface it with
to get to that fear they have to assume
they even had a chance right exactly you
know exactly which i'm sorry but they
don't so right right right right
it just it's absolutely [ __ ]
mind-boggling that that they project
that they are so scared that they might
run into a beautiful woman that might
have a penis and they're so scared that
they might like it like i don't
understand why they don't see that and
he's saying it not not even like in a
blog or on the show he's going on dr
phil
yeah yeah that's all which i do i do
want to
also bring up is like so he talks about
his book about the [ __ ] uh what was
it walrus right or
uh
uh i forget the the book i think it was
about a it was like a boy trying to be
in a walrus and like that whole thing
which is like you know how dangerous
that language is you know you're you're
making a kid's book and then you're
equating
saying you know what i'm not comfortable
my own body and i want to transition and
saying the transition is equivalent to
becoming an animal and that animal being
a walrus or whatever that
uh that creature is right like that's
how [ __ ] up it is right and it's like
oh i'm just making an analogy and it's
like no no no you're not just making any
analogy you're making an analogy that
all of a sudden you're gonna get husks
and you're gonna have [ __ ] uh you're
gonna have this you know fat body and
you're going to live in the water and
you're going to have to live in a zoo
aquarium whatever like
that's the message you're actually
sending that it's not something
beautiful you're transitioning to but
you're transitioning into something
that's like somewhat grotesque to people
right well but that's their fear right
and the fear is that is that a a a
a man could could transition to a
beautiful woman and they're terrified
they're terrible or a woman could
transition into a more handsome man than
themselves right and but they get but it
really is because they don't focus on on
the trans men like that's not their
focus it's always the trans women that
they're focused on which which also even
when it comes to sports is such a small
small small small small small percentage
of people who are even actively
participating in sports when they try to
be like oh well i care about swimming or
i care about this sport because now is a
man who transitioned into a woman okay
let's just get it out there
transitioning is a
emotionally uh physically
uh just medically medically draining uh
financially uh draining and just like it
takes a strong person to do that right
to realize that i don't feel comfortable
in the body i am and uh and i i i feel
more comfortable as a a man or a woman
or what have you right and
uh to transition to actually go through
that
and commit to that because that is who
you truly are and you believe you are
is so much stronger than any of these
other [ __ ] alpha cucks out there okay
and also that it just kind of rolls off
the tongue just alpha it does it does
well kaelin even says can we get some
alpha cuck merch so i'm gonna okay so
would you wear alpha just alpha cuck on
their shirt i don't know yeah i'm i'm i
i'm an alpha guy i'm not an alpha
get away from me alpha cuck i don't know
yeah the uh the other thing that too is
like within the sports realm
i guarantee you that if anyone were to
complain about a woman transitioning to
a man or rather see it's they never
complain about a woman transitioning
into a man in competition that's right
that's right they only they only worry
or not worry but they only like [ __ ]
it's all it's all about it's all about
and here's what yoda says and uh you're
scared she hasn't had bottom surgery and
has a bigger [ __ ] like that's all that's
all their focus is is only on trans
women they are so they [ __ ] hate
trans women so bad and because they're
so scared that they would like it right
that's the whole bathroom thing and all
that [ __ ] because no one no one who
[ __ ] [ __ ] about people going into
bathrooms isn't a weirdo in a bat like i
don't i don't think about other people's
genitalia when i go in a public bathroom
i go in i think i get the [ __ ] out right
and i will bet someone right now you
know a thousand dollars if they can
prove to me that someone transitioned
into a from a man into a woman
for the sole purpose that they wanted to
take advantage of people in the bathroom
i swear to god i will bet someone right
now if they can prove to me that
somebody went through all of that
years and years years right not like
it's not like they just woke up one day
and put it right right exactly like you
can say you feel one way like oh i you
know i feel more comfortable is if you
dress me as a woman or a man or whatever
or uh but it's the people that are like
oh well they're bringing uh they're
disgracing the sport of whatever
swimming track whatever right it's like
oh they have higher testosterone or what
happens like also there are women who
have higher testosterone levels than men
just naturally right right so like don't
even bring that up but then
[ __ ] human chemistry right exactly
it's like i'm sorry that you weren't
you're not as good as she is right like
alpha cuck right
man that really works really it does it
just releases like it's powerful you
know boom boom yeah uh like maybe maybe
instead of dishonorable with the
dishonor maybe we should have alpha cut
of the week too my own head of the week
and we do honorable mention and then we
give the alpha cuck right i think i
think it might become a thing okay well
anyway you get distracted no no no it
does it does uh it does roll off real
good real nice but the last thing i want
to say is on the sports side is these
people complain about oh like oh you
know they're they're making it um unfair
right it's unfair there's a competitive
advantage for these for for these men
who have transit transition into women
over
uh you know normal women right like
women who have been born that way and
stay their way and i look at that and i
say that's complete [ __ ] because
again you have to go through the actual
you have to actually transition to do
that not only that but when you're
taking hormones your body is changing it
is changing the way that it is
essentially put together right so it's
going to change a lot of things in terms
of like i compete one way as a man and
then if i transition into a woman then
my body like my structure my muscular
structure like this is all going to
change in how i actually perform that
sport so i could transition and i might
not be good anymore right
and so
the people that complain about it are
it's it's totally misguided in the sense
or rather it's intentional you know uh
outrage about something that they care
nothing and know little about especially
the sport well it's unfair yeah they'll
be like it's
unfair about track and they know they
could not even tell you the next person
on the list who has a record well
speaking of that because last night i
just i i thought i thought
this clip might exist
caitlyn jenner which she does know
something about participating sports
she does know something about
transitioning the other thing she knows
about is participating in men's sports
and women's sports right um she plays in
a women's golf right right so uh justin
has this posted here from fox news last
night uh fox news acres john roberts um
asked should sports discriminate and not
allow transgender athletes to compete
caitlyn jenner says boy that's a tough
one to answer then she starts talking
about um
how do you say that
hermaphrodites for oh hermaphrodites oh
my god jesus christ i haven't seen this
clip let's play this
so caitlyn let me ask you this question
if you could because uh former olympic
swimmer donna de verono was on first off
why is this person on fox news to be the
expert on this number one this is this
is the same thing when they have candace
owens or anyone else like oh how how do
black folks feel candace like oh my god
right
our air the other day and she pointed
out
and she pointed out that sports is
inherently discriminatory because she
couldn't become an olympic weightlifter
if she decided to because she just
doesn't have the stature and the in the
physical stature and the talent for it
but
should sports
discriminate and not allow transgender
athletes to compete
i mean he just said it discriminate but
okay boy that's right tough one um to
answer
um i think we right now
have to look at this issue a lot closer
i know the international olympic
committee number one why why is it such
a concern like you said who cares right
the amount of the amount of trans
athletes
oh my god it's like it dude it is so
small you know
the fact that someone would complain
about your com it's a you know what this
is it's [ __ ] voter fraud right it's
voter fraud all over again right the
voter id thing we're like oh you gotta
pass voter id right you pass all these
laws and then it turns out that the
actual voter fraud is happening from
within the party not from the people
that you're trying to suppress the vote
from and so you know they're like oh
well it's cheating because uh they have
uh you know
male testosterone levels and and they're
transitioning to women it's like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about these are
also people who have trained for [ __ ]
years if not decades to perform on an
olympic or you know for ncaa years up to
that level they're like this is what i'm
going to school for i got a
scholarship this is what i'm going to do
professionally this is what i'm going to
do internationally whatever it is this
is again this is something you just
[ __ ] roll out of bed and say yeah all
right well i'm going to become a man or
i'm going to be a woman just so that i
can compete at an advantage against
these other people and that's also not
that like you have no idea because these
other people could just be [ __ ]
better than you and they probably are
right so the fact that they're even
discussing this as a
again they even he even brought us like
should they discriminate oh what the we
did you just said it you just said it
you know
well and again it's this it's this alpha
cuck thing but let's finish what kate
caitlyn jenner has to say here because i
i want to listen to the [ __ ] just
probably the vile thing she says and and
pins up all trans people as
hermaphrodites or something
has been working on this subject for
years
back when i was competing all the women
had to take a saliva test
okay and to check
their dna to make sure they were female
the
soviet union the east german women you
remember i mean they had their coach the
athlete and a doctor working along with
them and it wasn't fair
and
the olympic committee has worked really
hard to try to find something they've
had
a hermaphrodite
bar basically born with both genders
and what do we do now
okay so even basically basically saying
that trans people are hermaphrodites you
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] number number one
uh this whole idea that they were trying
to make sure that women you know whether
that's true or not the saliva test if
that is true i don't
then here's here's the thing here's the
thing
if that is the truth and she's telling
the truth which she may or may not be
that just proves their [ __ ] theory
that all of a sudden trans people exist
right right like all of a sudden here in
2021 trains they if that's the truth
all those decades ago they were doing
that well then
right if that was an issue decades ago
then why like and you've
and you've been fine
since then right to say oh you know what
these people you know
competing or not or whatever like all of
a sudden in
you know the 2020s they're just like
[ __ ] you know now we're gonna like no it
didn't just happen
the biology of people like
i mean yes we have evolved whether some
groups have like regressed in nature you
know drinking their own kiss but right
right as we biologically have advanced
right or or just like developed
you know there's we haven't really
changed our
our makeup a whole lot in in the last
you know few hundred years right like
you look at it and you say you know
most people are the same in terms of how
they are you know especially like i feel
a certain way i want to be this i want
to be that whatever it is
yeah but to to to be so vile to pin up
uh a group of people especially a group
of people where she has transitioned
herself into as hermaphrodites like i
i'm not i'm not saying that
hermaphrodites don't exist but what i am
saying is to to to to try to scare the
fox news viewers yeah thinking that the
reason why you transition is because you
have both genitalia is just absolutely
100 [ __ ] false and and the fact of
the matter is is that why in the [ __ ]
does anyone care what gender anyone else
is if you are so insecure about your
[ __ ] gender and your sexuality that
you have to be concerned about what
everyone else's genitalia looks like
you're the [ __ ] weirdo
right and this is again this is ethan
schmidt [ __ ]
you know berating people about masks and
vaccines
you don't know this person they don't
know you
you don't live with them you're not
their neighbor they don't live in the
same city as you whatever they're you
don't even compete in this [ __ ] sport
because you're not good enough you all
right you suck
and so
i love you you look at it love it and
they just and it's a they look at and
they say i'm good i'm gonna love this
rage you know and they [ __ ] put it on
someone else and say it's not fair
because this person
you know whether they also have these
like insecurities and and are you know
dealing with the same thing and are like
mad that this person was strong enough
to say you know what i feel more
comfortable as this you know i want to
transition into this body
you know and they're upset you know it
really says more about the person who's
complaining about someone they don't
even know in a sport they don't even
compete about a sport they don't know
nothing they don't know anything about
right like that's what it is it's
projection it's this outrage this fake
outrage about some [ __ ] that nobody
[ __ ] cares about right right and if
it is really a thing about
you know like oh well
you know [ __ ] ratings or or whatever
like you know in terms of like uh
pay you know performance you know it
would only obviously just cause more
attention for those sports in general
which would bring awareness to those
things uh but really it's these people
complain about [ __ ] that doesn't
even matter
no one cares about well and it ain't got
to do with them and you know what i i
think that brings us to the bone end of
the week um where where
uh doing a lot of [ __ ] that that
you know caring about how other people
vote um kirsten cinema she's worried
about the rules she's worried about rule
changes because you know she's worried
about how people are gonna vote and if
they can vote i support the voting
rights act but i'm not going to do
anything about it right um of course you
know we we know that the senate tried to
debate to carve out the
the filibuster rule to make sure that
people can vote and and this is the
thing and i've been saying this all week
and i'm going to keep saying keep
pounding this drum it's that democrats
uh liberals
whatever whatever you want to say people
who aren't [ __ ] fascist
that that support voting rights actually
support it would actually do the things
to get it
aren't saying they only want democrats
to vote they're saying they want
everyone to vote we want everyone's vote
to count everyone
even the alpha cucks we want their vote
to count because we want to know i want
to know how many alpha cuts there
actually are yeah but but again i i
i don't understand why we can't get to a
point that that is the conversation that
democrats want everyone they want your
vote to count and they've they've gone
so far down in this rabbit hole of
election fraud and all this [ __ ]
that democrats are going to cheat to win
that a bill that allows that allows the
federal government to protect everyone's
right to vote even theirs
they get terrified of
because because they've been convinced
that george soros is funding some i
don't know dark man i don't know what
the [ __ ]
anymore but let's let's give let's give
senator cinema her due here and and
let's congratulate her on her win
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
man ethan schmidt didn't have a [ __ ]
chance he just that that that beta cuck
our alpha that alpha cuck
back there you know just like couldn't
even couldn't even i don't even know
what was probably i even helped him out
with one vote and i think that and it's
still and that was the only vote no it
probably oh not the only i mean he i
think he he uh he was under five percent
in total yeah it's like what am i
planning what a [ __ ] [ __ ] i will say
this i think i saw yesterday
uh
kirsten cinema was pulling at eight
percent or something like that oh really
i i thought i saw something about i i
don't know if it was down eight percent
or was eight percent oh either way
yeah yeah yeah either way i believe it
so
well you know uh it's not surprising for
her stance for this this voting rights
and i'm not even gonna go play the vile
[ __ ] [ __ ] that she said on the floor
of the senate because uh you know um i
support it but then i'm not going to do
anything about it
we had mansion and we had all the
republicans lining up acting like this
filibuster rule
is the only thing that matters to
democracy like number one that
[ __ ] was the founding fathers
you know they invoked the founding
fathers every time the founding fathers
didn't even know what the filibuster was
and the only reason why is because they
they they didn't give people civil
rights back then that everyone acts like
all those founding fathers gave us all
these freedoms they gave white
landowning dudes freedoms all right they
just [ __ ] up and made the constitution
where it was could be amended and that
we could actually change it and use the
constitution to actually grant all
people the rights that they wanted for
themselves to act like the founding
fathers were some kind of [ __ ] the
freedom fighters they were they were
slave owners who wanted for it to be
free
as george garland says look this is this
is bone-headed [ __ ] with this filibuster
because the filibuster the only time
it's ever been really used in history is
to stop civil rights bills like this one
they didn't stop it didn't stop [ __ ]
this republicans from ramming through
supreme court justices didn't stop him
then because that's not civil rights
yeah but anytime civil rights comes up
by god the filibuster has to stop it
because that's the rule the filibuster
is supposed to stop civil rights and
that's the way it is and that's the way
manchin and cinema like it is that they
can [ __ ] cow towel and hide behind
this rule debate
i don't know maybe i'm on my soapbox no
no i mean i mean that's what i watched a
video last night of uh i found myself
on uh
on ted cruz's instagram last night oh
jesus yeah it was a dark night uh
i i found it because there was that v
there was a photo of uh jamie lynn
spears and people were saying i think it
was james spears and people were saying
like it was ted like tell me it's not
ted cruz uh here let me see if i can
find i'll send it to you yeah um
but anyway i found myself there uh
through like the instagram explorer page
and then i started watching the video of
him explaining the filibuster and then
saying like how they you know they're
like oh well the democrats you know
wanted it and then they didn't want it
and they could have carved out you know
they could have like removed it for
supreme court justices but only did
below that because you know nominations
weren't up like up to bat or like
weren't a possibility so when they were
and then he was like yeah when the
republicans came in we you know we did
the same thing the democrats did and
it's like
oh god the [ __ ] just like
get rid of it right just make it fair
having a simple majority and allowing
people to actually debate as opposed to
just being like the class that or the
group that takes the ball and goes home
like that's all it is right like
and republicans are very much i mean
like you know politicians aside like
whatever the [ __ ] but
republicans are very much the party of
uh oh yeah this is totally fine until i
lose
or until i am not the one who is in
power and then it's not fair and then no
no guys no you know what uh let's let's
start over let's do it again
it reminds me of the kid like at a
birthday party and you know they're
playing some game and the birthday kid
loses so they gotta replay for him to
win yeah they got a replay or the kid
[ __ ] has a tantrum and he runs off
and the party is like oh this is so
[ __ ] awkward but at the end of the
day that's what it is it's a birthday
party for a kid the birthday boy loses
birthday girl loses and they throw a
tantrum and they have to redo it and
then be like okay guys okay just like
just we're gonna do it again but like
just like
act like you're playing but let them win
so they don't cry anymore about it right
like that's what it is and that's a good
point because that someone else brought
up this point i was talking about it i
think uh yesterday the day before is
that you know they're talking about the
rule change and and you know uh simple
majority versus the super majority for
the filibuster you know all these laws
that are being passed in these states to
actually suppress the vote
limiting ballot places limiting ballot
boxes
limiting the days you can vote for early
voting limiting absentee and mail-in
ballots doing all those things those are
all done with simple majority votes in
these states those aren't done with
filibuster votes those are all done with
simple majority but we can't get we
can't get these [ __ ] to agree
that it should be a simple majority vote
when you're protecting the actual
inevitable right of voting for people in
this country it is absolutely [ __ ]
boneheaded and ridiculous are you
sending me something from ted cruz's
instagram
uh
oh no no i'm i'm sending you the jamie
lynn
okay okay but i got distracted on my my
soapbox there and then i finally but
kirsten but kirsten cinema i believe um
i don't think she's going to remain the
the democratic candidate for senator um
i would imagine she's primary she
because the thing here is that by her
not protecting voting rights she pissed
off all the [ __ ] people who worked so
hard to get her elected the voters who
right
you know i mean like that's the thing
like why can't you [ __ ] see that
that this is a situation where you're
pissing all over the voters
right
what is this
is this ted cruz what
okay let's let's let's bring this up
here what it what explain what this is
it says so so this is jamie lynn spears
this is britney spears's sister right so
this is you know if anyone if anyone
knows what's going on obviously all this
[ __ ] tea is being spilled by britney
spears about her relationship with her
family now that she doesn't have a
conservative ship anymore and she's so
she so so you're saying she can spill
the beans now yeah i think there's also
a scheduled interview with oprah that's
going to happen of course there is yeah
i expect that to happen anyway so
this uh there was some interview that
she did and
and it and i saw this last night and it
kind of went like uh wildfire but the
angle of this and the photo people are
like oh this is his doppelganger if not
this is
this is ted cruz in a blonde wig like
that's what people are saying
so so
i i have to say here that um
i wish ted cruz if this is takers i wish
ted cruz would actually shave his beard
um
he he looked much less like an alpha
cuck without the i think
uh i think john
john walsh who we've had on the show
previously uh very funny guy talented uh
he has a video
uh that he has not released yet but i
saw him do a thing
on instagram live yesterday where he was
dressed up as ted cruz with the blonde
wig
and so i think i said there might be a
video dropping i think he might be
dropping a video today all right well
pay attention to john's john's account
uh it's john walsh i think is his hand
yeah yeah it's john exactly yeah
yeah i just checked his socials it has
not been done yet so i would imagine he
didn't get up in that makeup for nothing
right right so i would probably expect a
video maybe coming out later today well
you know i i'm i'm happy for for for
cinema that she won um because she
definitely was the bonehead of the week
you know mitch mcconnell came in there
at the very end as a dishonorable
mention
for almost the same cause for the voting
rights but let's give let's give
senator cena one more chance here at her
congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so thank you and congratulations to
kirsten cinema for participating in the
bonus of the week um if you guys want to
vote for bonehead of the week go follow
us at tony michael's pod the the poll is
there every week and follow me and gabe
also on twitter um we we're going to
move bonehead of the week but here's
what we're going to do just to tell
folks um it's going to be friday the
second hour of the show every single
week we're going to start at noon
eastern 11 central so bonehead will be
in the second hour of that show every
single friday uh also what we're going
to do is i think me and you talked about
we're going to cut it out and re-air it
on sunday so not only will you be able
to watch it inside the podcast
on friday in the second hour but we're
going to cut it out and we'll re-air it
so to be on youtube twitter twitch so
don't forget to subscribe over on
youtube
and so you don't miss uh just the the
single playing in case you want to
re-watch the bonehead of the week and
watch us you know totally drag these
[ __ ] to the mud
you can you can re-watch it live on
sundays i think we'll do it like what
eight eight eastern probably something
like that yeah you know we'll do it like
sunday night um and then again it'll be
over over on the youtube channel so
don't forget to subscribe over there so
thanks for bonehead of the week we'll be
right back um
after the song here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]